hi i'd like to talk about the the
weapons that we we train in the obama
aikido
uh i'm sure most of you will know that
osensi
said that you should do daily weapons
and he he put together a series of the
joe carter twenty just brewery
uh cytosins he put together the 31 jerk
character kumijo
and
over the years
when i first met cytosensei really the
kimmy joe was about the only thing in
the 13
count carter
and 13 count partner practice
it's gone on to
a six jokarta what's
i think's been created really by
us teachers deciding it's a really
small piece that we can
take from the 31
excuse me
and um
and teach a beginner
because you might not think that like
the 13 joe carter you might think that's
only 13 movements
it's because we perhaps know it so well
but to a beginner even a yellow or
orange belt fourth queue
it can seem a lot to remember because
you know they're working really hard
with their mind trying to get
the moves correct
and this really takes me on to
wondering why we do so many weapons and
what the values of it
i do think that
as in our style we we do a lot of
weapons and we
we need to because we have the belief
that
when doing weapons think of taijitsu and
when doing tai chi think of weapons
but in reality
when do any of you ever think that
you're doing tajitsu when you're doing
the weapons
perhaps you've discovered something i
haven't over the years
and you can tie it all together
with everything that you do
i cannot
yes the hasso
movement
i think everybody agrees
it reminds you of what you do with the
ribbon eggy you know with the arm coming
over
you can do
some sort of sheer naggy movements with
the joe with your partner
if you're doing uh
joe nager dory
you can do a kite and aggies and that
but but you know this is
like trying to look deep and finding
things
when you have to look
to find things that tie them together
aren't they really
what what it's intended to be no
it should
when your body moves
you should be experiencing the same
feeling with the ken and joe
as you experience with taijitsu
if you're doing a sheer nagging
if when lifting their arm and your arm
if that feels like the ken without you
becoming a stiff road bot
of such perfect technique that it's not
got any flow to it
then what have you achieved you know you
just you've become
a robotic movement
without feeling and understanding
i'm not knocking the weapons i'm just
saying that cytoscensia each stage
developed the weapons for a reason
he developed them
because once he started going out into
the world
it's a little bit like having six
chickens
and then when you've got 60 chickens you
need more food
so
he would make more varieties and each
winter when there's not many dashi iwama
you may know this
he would look at
mixing and changing the weapons
i've said before the kentai joe
was
what he done with his son in his new
dojo that never gets used now
for his ninth dan
he made a video of it presented to the
doshu because the doshu offered him
after 22 years
of him refusing his ninth then because
the way it was offered to him by the
doshu
he then said when he was offered again
after 22 years
by the doshu he said
if you accept this video
and you think that my techniques are
good enough
i will accept night then
so he made the kentai joke purely for
that
so if you've got to be a ninth dad to
understand this can you imagine
what chance
we've got even me at sixth dan
of understanding the kentai joe
most teachers do it because it adds to
the rep of 12 knowledge
and
when i was in my heyday of traveling the
world and training
i wanted to know the latest weapons i
wanted to get everything perfect so i
had to have the latest modifications
so really this message is about
asking you
how much
of taijitsu do you feel when you're
doing the weapons
if you've come up if you come up with
the same answers myself
i suggest you train more taijitsu
because taijitsu will get you
fitter
more flexible
the weapons give you accuracy
so
if you use the accuracy of your body the
alignment of your body
how you escape
be precise when you escape don't just
jump anywhere
don't just move anywhere
think of what you would do with the
preciseness of a cut
a ski
a hasso
a hapogiri
you find these things
and put them into your taijitsu
put the essence of what you should be
getting from the weapons
if you're up to knee down then i would
suggest you
just study the seven kensa brewery
the partner practice with ken
and the kumita is the five kim attaches
and variations
if you're above second down
then
perhaps
look at the
kent idea occasionally
but don't think that you have to master
it
some people have tried with the kumi joe
and again i think
try it any at any level the the ten kumi
joe
until you get to knee down
really the kumi joe
is very complex
so
i think it's better to stick to the more
basic
the twenty joe saburi
the thirteen carter
and the thirty-one joe carter
of course you'll want to do the partner
practices and the kumi joes
until you get a really good partner who
can attack you
vigorously
and with
intention it will never really be many
more than a set of choreographed moves
where you're both having fun
so my message in
in this is
why
are you doing the weapons
think about it hard
limit yourself if you can
to training
the most basic of weapons to get your
body accurate
check to see how
stressed you get
how tight you get
can you be sharp and yet relaxed at the
end of each
movement
does it get you more tenser the deeper
you go
by the time you've done the 31 have you
gone in and out of tension
um
because by relaxing through it you would
have been sloppy
please consider these things
to stay sharp all the time is difficult
if you do the twenty joe suberi with a
hundred percent intention you will be
exhausted by the end of it
if you do the 13 count carter
even though it's called a 13 count
carter it should have suburi feeling
throughout the carter
it's not for speed
and yet the 31 is for speed
so you shouldn't be doing the 31
as the suburbs you should be doing it as
a flowing movement so they're very
separate
i remember cytosensei saying the 13 joe
carter has all the suburbs that are not
in the 20 jose very
so
that explained it to me
that that's why you should do the 13 as
if each one is a suburi
you can do it fast if you want
but will it become sloppy will it become
not the superior feeling that you should
have
i hope this helps you
and
of course you'll question everything
and so you should
so
i wish you well in your quest
thank you for listening